[Music]
welcome to wisdom for life where we sit
through philosophy to find practical
advice that you can use in your everyday
life hi I'm Dan Hayes I'm joined by my
co-host Dr Greg Zer and today we're
talking about AI That's artificial
intelligence and ethical art so a little
bit of a departure for us but something
that I think um you know we're both
pretty interested in and it's becoming
more and more and more a part of all of
our Lives even if we're not using AI to
generate artwork ourselves eles we might
be tempted to somebody is right it's
being used for businesses to create
logos there's memes there's probably
going to be a lot of political ads that
incorporate AI generated art I expect in
this upcoming political season so you
know it's it's a topic definitely worth
delving into and what what made you want
to dig into this particularly Dan well
we're here for like practical you use
ful ethics or like philosophy and this
is a a topical thing that's happening in
the world over the last several years um
and it's only going to continue to go
forward if we're not thinking about this
in kind of deep and and systematic way
then we're going to either make bad
Arguments for the things that we want or
we're going to make bad decisions and so
I'm trying to apply this the tools that
we have within philosophy to help us
make better decisions is uh very J to
this program yeah and if we're not doing
it ourselves somebody's going to be
making arguments to us which then could
sweep us along or you know if we want to
have a what what would you say a seat at
the table in policymaking or even just
for institutions you know like what
should we do in a particular class or uh
in a business place um well we we got to
know what we're getting into and
understand the issues
involved and so to make choice is a
choice in of itself and to not speak
when there is important things to be
spoken about is also a choice so um kind
of want to set the stage a little bit
okay what is artificial intelligence we
talked about this a little bit before
but we want to make sure that we're all
the same
page um at very basic a um artificial
intelligence consists consists with
agents that have internal states that
can move through a medium and respond to
make decisions based on internal States
and the state of the medium that they're
traveling so this means that like if
you're a little robot you have an AI
that determines I want to take a left or
right if I see a wall in front of me and
it's it's got some internal like
decision-making mechanism that's going
to help it make a left or right and then
it will do that automatically and
proceed on until it hits another wall um
within what we're currently working with
nowadays like a lot of these um large
language models where the medium is the
chat conversation between you and the
bot it's taking the input the medium
which is your inputs and making
decisions based off of your inputs to
give it an output based on its own
internal States but you know the
examples that you picked so AR Roomba is
a very low-level AI right because it's
going around the room and it it tries
its best it's poor little thing to avoid
bumping into the table at first it'll do
that and then it it Maps out the room
unless you start screwing with it and
moving things around right or a cat's
you know jumping at it or something like
that um and it's it's responding to its
environment and gradually using this
internalized map to accomplish its task
which is to eat up all the dirt and dust
and grime and and it'll tell you when
it's full too so that's that's kind of
cool that's useful yeah rather than just
like well getting all more and more full
and eventually starting on fire that
would be a bad
outcome
and and you give it more sensors and you
can have it know different things about
it like there's someone that have like
um radar systems and they can like
really map out the room instead of just
like kind of walking through it in a
what we call
random yeah it will actually like oh map
the room first and then make a more
determined way to actually go through it
in a systematic way instead of this as
you said halfhazard
and and so these these things um can go
from the really really basic to some
things that are really really quite
impressive nowadays and that you know
what we're doing with uh these AI art
generators are they are still uh AIS but
their um their internal states are much
different than like a Roomba um and they
produce outputs that are not just uh
controls of what direction but um actual
art yeah you know at Milwaukee Institute
of Art and Design where a lot of people
are very very concerned about you know
what's going to happen with these things
it's interesting because I don't
remember I think it was last semester uh
that they advised us now this semester
required us to have some sort of AI
policy that each of us crafted within
our syllabus to give guidance to the
students because the students you know
they're not sure what to do with this
either it's kind of open
territory and the one that I came up
with there's not a lot of AI art that or
art in general in my classes because I
teach human ities classes they'll have a
few visual projects but they're usually
like interpreting something so like
world religions they're finding images
and then telling me what the images
actually signify and what their you know
meaning is to people in in that
particular religion but in other classes
it's really really important you know if
you're going to be
submitting potentially somebody else's
or something else's art well that could
be a problem so for me it's more the
textual issue right and as I thought
about it I was like well the students
are using AI anyway they should be at
least if they use grammarly they're
using a low-level AI which is you know
giving them advice that they would be
getting at The Writing Center or from a
friend who proof read their essay this
word would be a better word to use here
um maybe and I could actually
incorporate that quote from The Princess
Bride about you know not not thinking
you don't know what this word means
right that would be kind of a cool thing
to put in there but most of our students
wouldn't catch that reference
unfortunately because it's too dated but
then when it comes to the large language
model based um inputting inputting
prompts and then spitting things out you
know there was a big debate about how
should we view this is this cheating is
this plagiarism and I I actually um
argued that it's not
plagiarism because to plagiarize you
actually have to have like a source text
that you're taking something from not a
whole amalgam of of all sorts of texts
that you're sifting things from and then
generating something new but that it was
cheating if the student was passing off
say chat gpts stuff as their own work
that would violate absolutely yeah and
so what my my thing was to say all right
you can use chat GPT or you know
whatever other equivalent system you
want but you have to do two things one
is you have to actually um document that
just as you would with any other
borrowing from any text from somebody
else right so you've got to cite it uh
and then the other thing is you're
responsible you're on the hook for
making sure that the information that is
being conveyed by that is accurate and
factual so if you're going to use it to
answer a discussion forum about a book
that you decided not to read because you
were being a little lazy or Cy or
something thing and you're going to I'm
just going to ask the computer to solve
this for me if the computer makes stuff
up well you're on the hook for that you
know you're going to lose points because
you didn't fact check it and so you know
what is the uh outcome of this most of
the students it's not worth it to them
to to to use it right so someone's like
oh give me a quick summary of The Grapes
of Wrath and it goes out oh The Grapes
of Wrath is a book about a um Italian
World War II uh platoon
that had many behind the lines exploits
like oh that's that's very interesting
where did you come up with that
hallucination well and how would they
know if they don't actually know what
they're asking about I mean this is I
think one of the dangers more with text
based stuff although maybe this does
apply to AI art if you're asking yeah if
you ask for like a make something in the
style of
Picasso but you don't actually know what
Picasso's Style looks like how do you
know if it's getting it right or not I I
imagine it's at this point in time it is
getting it right it usually does yeah
but how would you know if you don't
actually know the
field that is great and we'll get to it
in a moment but I want to also finish
that the the groundwork here so uh
neural networks are a very Advanced type
of um AI um that use uh what we call
neural networks which are very um rough
simulacrum or a lossy version of what um
some computer researchers were trying to
do to model a human mind or a brain and
how neurons particularly interact with
each other um it is not a Ono one
obviously um but um there are two main
ways that we teach or we uh build these
models we have either uh teaching
through um having an actual teacher so
you say like here's the expected here
are the inputs and I want you to have
these expected outputs and I just give
like a whole bunch of those examples and
that that works really well for very
certain tasks um but uh one of the more
interesting things is these um
undirected learning which says um it
gives you a function and it says try to
maximize this function and so one of the
easiest ways you can see this is they
had a model that was running through all
these old Atari 2600 games and over
every single one of them has a little
score in the top right counter and it
says make that number go up and so it
has a little function that can determine
what those pixels turn into
numbers I need to make those go up and
it tries a 10,000 different things and
figures out uh ways that no one had ever
even tried before to like make that go
up um it's it's really interesting to
watch them like fumble in the dark
because they all start off and they like
they go every which way and they don't
know what to do and they don't know what
buttons to press and and they're just
firing randomly and they're just like
looking and eventually they figure out
certain things but you have one of these
things it's a an issue with lots of um
different uh computer science um tasks
is falling into local Min or local
Maxima yeah so you say like you're
you're you're going up this way and then
you have a peak but then there's a
valley and then there's another Peak
that's even higher to the right of that
and so a lot of times they'll get stuck
in this little Peak and they'll try to
optimize and optimize and optimize and
you have to make it sometimes go um
searching for different solutions I mean
it's sort of like getting caught in a
culdesac in a subdivision you know and
then needing to back out and find
another way to get to right yeah and
this process is called a simulated and
heeling you know they used a term back
there that I think maybe some of our
listeners would need you to explain
lossi um and it it also applies to you
know what we do here with recording
right right so like you know say um you
take a Xerox you take a Xerox of a xerx
and there's every time that you do that
you're you're going to get a little bit
less information the copy is in it's
perfect and um yes where exactly was I
using lassi there talking about the
neural networks and the you know um ah
are they like a a brain or not or is is
a neuron like a is a neuron in a neural
network like a neuron in a brain so this
this comes down to um the the train is
not the map and so anytime that you're
trying to model something or to map
something the map is going to be a uh a
less granular representation of the
thing and so these the the perceptrons
are which the computer science term for
what a uh the idea of what a neuron
would be in a brain is a um a data
structure that has um an uh input and a
number of inputs and usually
number of inputs or number of outputs
and they have a a value between zero and
one that's supposed to potentially be
infinite but it's usually cap at like
256 um to determine the uh value in
which the uh perceptron itself will fire
on to the next one and so the the number
of inputs and the number of outputs and
the number of layers within this
structure um produces outputs depending
upon the the values that are going into
it and um to the next layer this is kind
of in the weeds the point is is that
this is a when they said a culac a lossy
version of what it is because we're
trying to map something that is real um
in uh silicon or computer code yeah and
to be fair I mean in our analog lives
most of the things that we're doing are
lossy in that way I mean every word that
we use is you know referring to all
these different things and you know does
it does it refer perfectly to any one
single thing no you know try try to give
a description of your emotional states
at any given point in time that's
actually accurate rather than just
saying well I feel mad or I feel sad or
something like that and you you discover
how difficult this is or coming back to
the visual things I mean try to write
down what your favorite artwork actually
looks like like you know and see how
well you can convey
that there's going to be an awful lot of
loss going on of information right yeah
I've done this I have particular piece
of art where I love it oh really yeah
it's at the um it's a a sculpture in the
Madison chasen Museum of Art and it's
okay and you tried to write like a
written description I could write like a
paragraph and it wouldn't come close to
describing the intricacies of this
particular piece but um uh to to finish
off so a model that we're talking about
when we're talking about AI is usually a
neural network that's trained to do a
thing um and uh models are incredibly
useful and they're definitely not going
away um and so any blanket bands against
them are unlikely to actually work um as
this is a very distributed technology
and they will be developed someplace in
the world um and there's
not any sort sense of single World
governments that there's no lever to
pull to actually do that so how do we
live with these in a way that is
actually useful yeah as if there's a
lever to pull for anything on the
internet right right like somebody can
push a button or flip a switch and now
you can't get this I mean you can take
sights down but yeah they have mirrors
in other places and yeah how long is the
pirate B been up oh I don't know you
know forever it gets knocked down all
the time yeah pops right back up
again um so um we we've got some really
uh big moral questions and um Now Greg
what do you think about any of the moral
questions yeah I mean I can tell you
that there's before we even give it into
moral questions I would say one of the
signs how important this is is the
amount of on the one hand un I would say
largely undo optimism that a lot of
people have about these these things and
then the amount of just sheer fear
that's out there like you know we're
going to talk about some of these things
artists will no longer exist in 20 years
you know because anything that you want
them to create you'll just you know
create a set of prompts and get it
yourself so who would ever go to art
school and get trained in in these
things it'll become a boutique kind of
uh craft or or something like like that
right so you know and then there's a lot
of worries about well artists are very
concerned about their their own Works
being put into these models whether they
like it or not if they you know because
these days if you're an artist I mean I
suppose you could have a non-online
existence where you have nothing of
yours available in a digital form but
most artists are on
Instagram and a number of different
platforms that are specifically for
artists to showcase their work so that
people will hire them or so they can
send a portfolio to a gallery and say
maybe you'd like to show my work or you
know apply for Grants or all the things
that are essentially the economic
lifeblood of a creative artist whether
you're doing you know traditional media
like painting or sculpture photography
or are you doing Digital Arts you know
um there's a lot of worries about your
stuff and your distinctive Style getting
copied by no longer somebody else
plagiarizing you because there's already
like big companies out there stealing
people's designs and putting them on you
know uh cheap T-shirts and stuff like
that not paying the artists anything and
um but now it's you've got to worry
about um large language models owned you
know by companies taking your your stuff
and putting it into a database where it
might remain
forever right and
so yes I'll add a little bit to this
because you hit most of the the major
points here um yeah there's this
economic incentive or disincentive if
you have that there like there at least
there's the worry that these will
supplant artist jobs and thus you'll
have less art and you'll have less human
creativity yeah um yeah I think there's
a lot of people in design who who are
like well I know that I can do better
stuff than what can be generated but the
average person on the street who wants
to Hye me how am I going to make the
case to them that they they should be
supporting a human being when they can
just get a subscription to you know some
some platform and then put in 30 prompts
and get what they want for their
business logo or their latest um
announcement you know that goes with
their their event or press release or
something like that I mean this is the
stuff that artists you know it's their
bread and butter
right and another one is like we feel
weird as humans when we a machine does a
thing that we think that only humans
should be doing so there feels like
there's something that is taking away
the
humanity by removing this creative
Pursuit that we like find as really
intrinsically
human uh yeah I mean you you could say
like an artist has
to build up their repertoire and skill
and Sensibility through a lot of you
know screwing around and doodling and
experimenting but I mean you could say
that these uh models are doing that when
they're being
trained in a way it's not quite the same
thing as like sitting in a boring class
and you know making a caricature of your
teacher I'm just thinking about a friend
of mine from high school who used to do
that he was very very good you know and
of course didn't do anything with his
art you know
um uh but you know maybe there's some
equivalent of doing things like that for
AIS yeah to to a different like and I
don't want to go too into the weeds of
exactly how they do this it's a
diffusion technique but um but yeah they
are doing this with you have like okay
take every single Picasso um and you
like this is you you label all these
picassos and it knows you know at least
the style of Picasso after it like has
ingested all these picassos and can then
start spitting out things that look like
Picasso that are not picassos yeah and
it's not as if that hasn't been done by
human beings who I mean once any any
artist who became popular there are
people who have imitated their Styles as
a matter of fact that's part of your
training as an artist at least with
certain media is you go into the museum
and you copy paintings or drawings or
that that is exactly um and last last
main one of these worries is um for whom
does this benefit like um well there's a
Latin term for that right uh quono yeah
quono yeah yeah um so uh this is taking
money out yeah yeah exactly and so um we
have a whole bunch of different models
we've got mid Journey stabil divion
diffusion um Dolly one and two there's a
whole bunch of them out there um and
they do these things really well um and
so just as you were saying like
um we say that we can like own the the
intellectual property of individual
pieces of art um and even potentially
subsections of the piece of art um but
uh not the technique which we use to
produce that technique and these are
Styles right and so like we're just as
we were saying like you know you go to
the museum and you sit down in front of
a Monae or O'Keefe and you you sit there
you draw it or you then you take it home
and maybe paint it or um that that is
the process of becoming an artist is to
ingest these these arts and um
eventually find your own style and
produce your own unique works yeah I
mean it's interesting because if we're
thinking about visual stuff like we got
art that we consider art with a capital
A like way over here on the other side
and then we've got like you know the
kind of stuff that um you know we were
talking about using prompts to generate
uh you've got a uh event coming up you
need a poster for it you know normally
you would hire a graphic artist to
produce that but you you put it into
that and you have like 30 designs
generated by an AI and you're like I
like this one we'll go with this and
then you've got the stuff that's like
you know really low level like a logo
and you know you you can claim that
somebody is infringing on your style if
you're a corporation and somebody
you know like say you know Pepsi or Coke
or something like that um you can make
claims and they do in lawsuits and every
once in a while they win and a lot of
times they lose because just making that
curse for the cocacola if you wanted to
say like you know poopa Cola or
something like I probably avoid the cola
part too so you know probably um poopa
puka or something like that you probably
could get away with that but the the
corporation might sue you anyway yeah so
there's like a spectrum right yeah um
but we we do make a delineation we don't
know exactly where like the the
delineation is a little bit fuzzy but
there's definitely like on the edges
it's it's really quite apparent okay um
and so uh I guess I'm not trying to make
the the distinction like exactly where
that line is but that there are two
different things here at very least yeah
and so very same things like we don't um
uh copyright cells because so if someone
like copyrighted um rock or R&B or
country or something then like we will
lose almost all of our music we can yeah
I mean the the difficulty of of doing
any of those is that they're so vast it
you know so just to give you kind of a
in the weeds example I do this classic
metal class with some of my my friends
and one of the important musical history
parts of it is the new wave of British
heavy metal and the new wave of British
heavy metal like revitalized the whole
metal scene in the late 70s early 80s it
came over here to the states and other
places and it was really quite important
but there's when we were like well what
is the new wave of British heavy metal
sound there is an a sound there's a
bunch of different interconnected sounds
and they have certain features in common
with each other and others not and you
know there's different genres within
that as well so it would be very
difficult to do that it's sort of like
saying let's copyright painting you know
right or photography you just can't do
anything that that large but you can
certainly you can certainly say that
like um somebody anom kefir both in
painting and photography has a style uh
you know that you could emulate emulate
yeah but but does that make it like we
were just talking about like you take a
Picasso or just because he's alive does
that make it any less wrong to emulate
his style well you know this is where I
guess a lot of it would come down for
many people to the the the question why
are you doing it right and you know the
the answers to that could be well I'm an
art student and I want to learn how this
person did their thing just like if
you're if you're a musician and you want
to get better you play the stuff that
other musicians have played and you kind
of try to figure it out from the inside
I mean I think you can say that with
coding too right you look at somebody
else's coding you're like what the hell
was this person thinking you know uh and
then you then you see it so I mean even
with mathematics following along
somebody else's proof there's there's
often more than one way to to prove
something and you could be like why did
they take that step there well now I now
I understand it so there's a educ
ative Motif to it you could say and then
it could be you just like at the other
end I just want to rip them off I just
want to pretend that I'm this person and
get paid to do their stuff okay that's
you could say that's that's ethically
problematic right are you talking about
like like being a cover band or type
thing or are you talking about like the
monkeys to The Beatles well I mean a
cover band doesn't pretend that they're
the actual band right so if you go to
see a Kiss cover band they're putting on
the makeup right odds are every single
one of those people in that band is
younger than at least two of the people
in in actual kiss who just retired you
know finally because they're in their
70s
um you I just realized that kiss is one
of those perfect bands that you can just
hand down generation to generation
there's so much makeup on it that you
could you can cosplay that forever it's
kind of like the Blue Man Group this is
an interesting one and I think can tie
it in with this they had a idea they
were kicking around for a while because
there's there's two original members
Jean Simmons the demon and Paul Stanley
the the star child right and they've got
two other guys uh Tommy theer and I
think Eric Carr dressed up as the
spaceman who was originally Ace Freely
and the Tom Cat who was originally Peter
Chris right and then they're all in the
makeup and they and they play great you
know um and the and the younger guys are
are younger you know they're like in
their 40s or maybe 50s so Jean Simmons
and Paul Stanley who own the band were
like well what if we just found another
guy to be Jean Simmons and another guy
to be Paul Stanley and we put him in the
makeup and they've got the you know
they've got the sound down because you
can easily find musicians who love kiss
and would love to step in there and
we'll just license it you know yeah and
they will go out and they'll be us and
we'll we'll collect the money until we
die and then maybe it'll continue on
even after us so they were actually like
kicking that idea around and they
decided not to do it I I'm not sure why
but what did they decide to do instead
have you seen the recent so they created
avatars computer generated avatars that
I'm not surprised look terrible I mean
um people who look at them they're like
what in the hell is this anime crap you
know it's it's it's really quite silly
you know they've got like you know all
sorts of weird computer generated things
floating around them and they they don't
they they look I mean I'm sure some
people like the aesthetic and I'm sure
the guys who signed off on it must like
it but that is their continued graphic
representation that presumably can go
and deliver concerts somewhere yeah you
know I feel like they they've done like
the the fake Tupac and a couple there's
a company that does that and they
actually make really lifelike
representations it's weird that they
took that are they are they Holograms or
are they okay because I was GNA say you
wouldn't want like an animatronic thing
no
um but I mean that is a visual image
right so it's not it's not the same
thing as these static images that we're
talking about but why do these images
have to be static I mean if you go to
the um these these things that they have
now uh and I can't remember what it what
the original name is but it's like
they've done it with Van go and mon
they've come here to the Wisconsin
Center and you go in and the whole room
oh the experiences is is it is it
experience van it's like the van go
experience the yeah yeah and and they've
got the the images but they're they're
moving so it is it's uh and they're
transforming into each other so there
must be some computer gener at stuff
making that that happen um I mean that
that could be done I mean imagine like
you had a room with projectors in it or
just you know screens on the wall and
you're like I'm super super into Claude
Monae um AI whatever it is please
generate for me endless variations on
Claude Mona's water Liles yeah my uncle
would love that he was into uh Monae so
much that he named one of his cat's claw
oh really yeah so
um I guess one of the things I wanted to
make sure that we were talking about was
this this worry about like um the art
and where it is in these models and so
yes they do build um models out of
artworks but the artworks themselves
don't reside as image representations
within the model they are there in the
data set that you build it from but once
it is put into the data set all you have
is um these nodes and the uh the values
that represent the
um uh the edges between the two nodes
that make up the actual model um and so
there's it's a a distinction but is I
think an important distinction when
we're talking about like them saying
that there or some artists will make the
argument that it's actually in the model
yeah and so it's not actually copied
they took it they they or they looked at
it and did very something that we just
talked about going to museums looking
through art books finding Arts that you
like and you ingest it um and you you
understand it and then you can reproduce
a SIM lcam without actually having the
actual thing there to reproduce pixel
for Pixel I wonder if there's anybody
and I think you'd really have to be
quite a lite to be making this claim but
you know the the the art world out there
is full of quirky types if there's
anybody who's like I don't want my work
being transformed
into uh a bunch of Digital Data
essentially a set of relations
between pixel colors right um that's
inherently wrong you're you're ruining
my art in the process I mean you could
say to them well I mean your painting's
still there right I mean we didn't like
uh destroy it in order to do that we
didn't put it into a machine
that broke it down into its component
parts or something but I I suppose they
you know there's probably people out
there who like don't digitize me man you
know
yeah and so I guess have you seen
anything like that or I mean is would
that just be like totally out there
Fringe um there are some artists that
will
like there's there's actually quite a
few that don't want them as part of the
data set there is a smaller subset that
think it's actually in the model itself
um but I guess the the argument that we
we're talking about specifically is like
um who who gets to like ape an image who
like the whole learning process is every
human that wants to be an artist goes
through this thing of of trying to
reproduce other great pieces of work or
at least other great Styles and we don't
have zero problem about that and this is
actually one of the main cruxs is of
this whole issue is that we have
something that feels wrong as we talked
about in our our uh moral issues here um
and we're trying to put our finger on
why it's wrong um yeah so from the
standpoint the AI is not doing anything
different from any other artist no
artist needs to pay for it license to
all the art they've ever seen in every
Museum or book they've ever seen and
this would be absurd and would prevent
any new art from being produced ever
again if I had to you you only so like
if you're an artist and let's say you
take a a picture right you go into a
museum and it's of a living artist so
it's not like they're long dead and you
don't have to worry about them you take
a picture of uh somebody's
artwork and you know you can put that on
your social media if you want to and be
like Oh saw this cool thing and you're
not going to get in trouble it's when
you try to sell it yourself that you
wind up in in problems right right so a
isn't plagiarism or copyright
infringement in the tradition sense um
but it still doesn't stop us from
feeling this weirdness about it and so
um I wanted to just grab into writing
really quick this is very similar things
that happens that we we read all these
things if we want to be a a novelist um
and we find things that we like we find
little bits and pieces and H um even uh
Huntress Thompson the great Gonzo
journalist um wrote and transcribed the
great gaps Fe word for word on a
typwriter not once but twice in order to
get the feeling of what it's like to
write a great American novel wow right I
don't know everyone should be doing that
but that's that's some Dedication that
sounds like some tedious work
there um but like we ingest all these
things and all all of our influences and
you know it'd be like if every fantasy
writer since you know the from the 19th
or the 20th and the 21st century had to
pay royalties to you know Jr token
because he's like this Godfather like
you can't you can't get around his
influence within fantasy yeah and people
don't do that because that's just not
how we create art that's not the the
process so um this whole idea of you've
got to license these things doesn't seem
to fit the Paradigm that we've been
working with uh already I wonder if part
of the this is the vague feeling that
this is wrong is a associated with the
idea that it's it's not being earned by
the person who's using an engine
essentially right if we want to use
oldfashioned 19th century terms they're
using a calculatory engine to create
this thing and all they're doing is like
pushing a couple buttons now they're you
know they're not just pushing a couple
buttons they're using words and they
have to the more descriptive you are
with your prompts the the better stuff
you tend to get um and they they also
have to do kind of like look through all
the different selections and say well
this one sucks I like this one let's
let's you know work on on this a bit so
it's not like they're not doing anything
but you compare the amount
of yeah and and the sort of the back
trail of so you learned how to use the
English language and how to throw
prompts into a computer that to you know
learning the English language well you
did that as a kid and then throwing the
prompts into the computer that didn't
take you that long this person has been
working on Art since middle school and
and you know it seems it it feels like
maybe what you what you're doing in
generating AI art that would substitute
for an artist a professional artist work
is um a kind of getting ahead so it's
sort of like taking uh steroids to get
to bulk up at at the gym ra I mean you
still have to lift weights right but um
you know you're going to have some
pretty crazy gains I mean you're also
going to have some nasty side effects um
but um you know when we see people doing
that we're like yeah that's kind of
cheating you know or what else what
where else do we feel people are
cheating well just to like it comes out
to like you know it's not even like uh
steroids there you still got to like do
the the work a little bit but like it
still takes time whereas like this you
can produce a piece of art that would
have take you an artist like 404 or more
hours potentially and can do it in
seconds this is like literally thousands
of times the
rate of a a good uh artist doing
something in a similar quality um or
probably just in terms of the technical
work itself right yeah so yeah um like
there seems to be this Great Leap
Forward at least from like the output
point of view doesn't mean that it's
actually going to be good art
technically potentially proficient um
but um you know
once again this is like this thing that
it's like what we have this like deep
fear of like is this doing something
that humans are supposed to do
exclusively um but well let's explore
that one I mean that that seems to be
different in kind than the feeling that
like you're you're doing something
unearned you're you're you're you're
cheating somehow so if I understand you
right you're saying art maybe like other
activities maybe we want to talk about
this we'll probably hit on this uh this
this topic of AI and and Automation and
things like that again so the thing that
comes immediately to mind is like there
are people out there who are saying well
you know in the future what we're going
to have are sex dolls that you put in AI
in and it falls in love with you and
treats you like you're the best person
in the world you know and then most
people are in a certain sense rightly so
are like that's uh creepy you know don't
do that and and why do they do that
because they feel like well this should
be this
is distinctively human activity that
shouldn't be turned over to machines you
know reproducing art like you know you
make a nice print and you tell a robot
that you know let's say it's actually
you know fairly smart robot hey make me
a thousand of these that's what we do
with the Xerox machine right right um or
a printer but having it doing the actual
human creative work that's where a lot
of people would say oh no no you're
you're uh you're transgressing there
yeah yeah
but I
mean artists have done things in the
past like automatic writing or just
dropping paint onto a canvas in random
ways that seems pretty
mechanical yeah um is that no
longer worthy of human beings I you know
I don't know
um what do you think about
that I I feel like there's there is you
know Jenna squa about what humans
produce like for example I just recently
commissioned a couple artists to help me
um produce a logo and
um I went looking for art that was
trying to help me kind of like solidify
the idea that I was looking for I I did
uh use an art generator just to like
throw some things and see what that
could like potentially do is mostly for
like trying to like solidify some ideas
of of imagery kind of together um was
that helpful for you or not was it
helpful for you to do that or not
slightly I felt like I I needed a better
model to with um because I've seen some
other models that can actually kind of
sort of produce uh logos and whatnot but
this it felt like it was way off the
Mark um and um but only through this
like back and forth with an artist that
actually had the skill that could really
I could convey with words and pictures
exactly to them what I wanted was I able
to get something that really felt like I
could represented what I was looking for
um so that that back and forth
collaborative aspect of it uh in part
because okay they are able to speak back
to me not just with like an image have
that
conversation so in that case it's the
dialogue between
people that's an important part of the
creative process and that that's I think
that's really important to point out
because a lot of people have this
mistaken idea that creativity is like
this thing that you do all by yourself
and it comes totally out of you or what
you're you know seeing in the
environment the isolated artist but that
ain't the way art really works most of
the time you are seeking feedback and
there's like an iterative process I was
wondering though let me throw this idea
at you so if somebody wanted to say okay
AI generated art is um TR it's stepping
over the line is doing something that
should be distinctively human well there
is something distinctively human that's
happening that leads to the AI art being
better and that's giving the prompts I
mean the more
descriptive and articulate you are the
better art you're going to or the you
know more interesting art you're going
to get if you're just like hey man make
me a wizard on a mountain with a dragon
overhead you know for my uh my fantasy
van or something like that well you're
going to get some schlock right but if
you're like okay what I want to see is
this and I want to see it in this way
and this person's style should be
incorporated with these features but not
these features I mean there is this
whole thing out there that people are
trying to make into a discipline now
that they call Prompt
engineering um maybe
well maybe that's a distinctively human
activity you know as well as like that's
that's for like a whole image and
there's a whole thing like with in
painting where you say like I want this
you get a a first image you chop out a
section of it like actually want later
to be a fairy princess on a toad stool
right in the place where I just erased
and we'll do that and keep everything
else so but um I want to get to this
this new paradigm but like there's this
just finish up the the the problem here
is that there's this worry about like
all these workers losing their jobs
replacing something um made with the
human hand with a machine and so can we
find some you know moral legal framework
that addresses this issue and modifies
the feeling that something is morally
off um so I guess I had I had an issue
with a lot of the arguments that people
are using against this AI art um because
you can you know copyright uh a
particular image or like Subs images but
you can't really uh copyright a um a
style because then you you've basically
destroyed the ability to actually teach
our art students art
um yeah and and you know style also is
something that it's rather
intangible and it might not be all that
absolutely distinctive to a person and I
I have I read something recently um from
uh it's in the music field so you know
Eddie Van Halen is known for this really
new uh technique which he didn't come up
with he actually took it from other
people and then refined it into tapping
right and that was like his distinctive
guitar style and I was reading this
interview with this uh other guitarist
from another band that was big in the
the ' 80s called autograph and he he
came up doing that style too he was a
lead guitarist he didn't learn it from
Eddie Van Halen they were doing it
basically around the same time and
autograph was um opening for Van
Halen and um this guy was so good at
doing the tapping thing that he actually
like wrote some music books about it and
I think maybe did some videos I like
learn how to T right yeah so Van Halen's
management went to him and and said you
may not do any tapping while you're on
stage opening for Van Halen
and he was like well this is kind of BS
right so he went to Eddie Van Halen and
he was all kind of you know ticked off
and he's like Hey where's this coming
from man and Eddie Van Halen hadn't
heard about that and so he explained it
to him and he's like oh I'm gonna talk
with these guys you go ahead and do
whatever you want to on stage because
you know he's he's great he's not
threatened by somebody else doing a
similar technique that isn't exactly the
same you know um whereas somebody who is
more insecure
not as good of a musician might have
been like yeah man you can't do you
can't steal my my yeah exactly right and
and I I would imagine that in the art
world there's probably lots and lots of
stuff like that where you could be like
well this one here kind of looks like
he's stealing stuff from this person
over here and you'd be like well that
ain't the case you know um they they you
know different people can you know kind
of converge on the same idea you know
yeah yeah you know what is it uh Newton
and Leets for C oh I was just thinking
about that yeah um so
uh is the
um artist class of thing that we want to
sacrifice for cheaper art and who own
Styles if we going to like build these
AI art generation models um so like as
we're talking about between like art and
Styles um here's here's a a potential
proof on ownership um so things can be
owned by no one an individual a group an
entity or everyone this is a none some
or none one some or all okay um if uh
someone owns a thing then they have used
to it um styles can't be owned by one
person a group or an entity so that is
basically one or some okay yeah yeah and
uh they are not owned by no one as we
all have freeuse to access them
therefore styles are collective property
owned of humans okay and so therefore AI
is a collective good issue and not an
intellectual property issue and we
already have Frameworks for that so we
have public Airways we have public
waterways we have public mineral level
Lumber resources well would that require
then because all these AI art generators
at this point in time and I think we can
generalize this about um other AI things
that are similar so I won't say like you
know your your Roomba or something like
that but you know chat GPT or stuff like
that they're owned by companies that
because it takes that sort of level of
resource you can't just like build this
you know like the early days of
computing you know making computers out
in your garage or something like that
you know you you really need corporate
resources to be able to do this does
that mean that those
corporations in so far as they're
putting together platforms that are
allowing for this they have to be
treated like Public Utilities because I
don't think those those companies are
going to like that idea I wouldn't
called them Public Utilities but think
of it like a a labor oh sorry A Lumber
Company okay they go and they want to
harvest and freeze on public land yeah
um they they bid on and buy uh Lumber um
access and then they have certain
responsibilities to replant those trees
um afterwards and um then the the
benefits of those then go to um either
uh to public government
coffers or direct payments to Citizens
or providing public goods so for example
Alaska they have a Ubi anyone in Alaska
gets uh resource rights for the the oil
and other minerals that are being
extracted from
it just automatically gives everyone a
certain basic income
yeah equivalent so I guess two things
here what what's the equivalent with AI
art and these companies then to the
universal basic income your little cut
of the revenue that's
generated and then I I'm struggling to
see what the you know extracting res
sources but also replenishing them
cutting down trees and then replacing
them what is the equivalent of that here
with
artwork well I would say it's it's
probably easiest to do with the uh the
mineral rights okay and so like hey
there's this Collective thing that we
all own we all get benefits from it if
you want to have some private ownership
of that um then you need to provide a
benefit to um at the the collective
ownership of that so I would think like
because we're talking about art and we
want to continue to promote art the best
way to do that would be to create some
sort of um Arts funding um and so like
hey you want to be an artist hey we we
want culture and we want art these guys
are over here where they're using that
and they're going to make a whole
shitload of money but because they're
using the public resource to produce
that art and those things they need to
pay in to make sure that there are more
art more people that can do art and
instead of having this kind of um
sometimes perverse antagonistic yeah
sort of relationship yeah money as like
a job
specifically you can do art for Arts
sake and potentially even like obviously
constraints are sometimes really good
for art but also to allow them the more
freedom to produce whatever they
actually want yeah so so I mean to make
this a little bit more tangible and
concrete
the money that these companies are
generating and some of them might not be
making any money at this point in time
right but let's assume they're making
money right right would would go into
like
funding galleries or supporting more
grants for artists or you know the sort
of things that already exist that would
would make it possible for more people
to spend at least some of their time um
having that be their their main source
of of
income um and you know we we'd put aside
all the worries about like well who's
going to disperse the money who's going
to make the decisions about what's good
art and what's bad art and stuff like
that but I mean that's not a bad idea
actually I I kind of like that um what
would happen then to people using these
platforms to do the sort of things that
people are doing today which is like hey
I want some cool art for my um album or
um my poster or something like that mid
Journey make it for me you know um right
now it seems like you can do that if
you're if you're if you're actually a
subscriber that that's okay right
um but you might make tons and tons of
money with something that you're getting
from one of these AI generated art stuff
would the companies actually be cool
with that or are they going to want to
cut oh that these are the the minutia
that makes you know sometimes can
destroy an idea
uh I guess this was mostly
a I'm not buying the argument that they
were originally making but I feel that
this as a public good issue is a better
framework to actually I think there's
potential here um and I also do
like the there's two things I like about
it one is you're saying okay there's a
lot of arguments floating around out
there they're they're popular arguments
they're not really good arguments I
think that's an important thing to to
signal and then I I also like getting
away from the sort of like zero sum
antagonistic um current Paradigm that we
typically have with this sort of stuff
like you know the this damn AI stuff
it's going to put us all out of business
you know whether it's um art or write
content writers or um you know there
there's worries about doctors are going
to be replaced by AIS with robots cuz
you know they are using AI in in um uh
uh x-ray Imaging to to find things that
doctors have a hard time finding great
that's awesome you know if if it results
in less people having uh health problems
that's that's really cool I mean you
still need a you know a radiologist to
look at the stuff and sign off on it um
but they're in general actually higher
rate of like finding a cancer follow-ups
or whatever yeah then you're best
radiologist it's just like they're built
to do that one thing yeah so you know I
I kind of like the let's not make it all
about you know well we were joking
before this about something coming from
a
Sci-Fi um series The you know Dune
series by Frank Herbert and the Butler
and Jihad and the line Thou shalt not
make a machine in the likeness of a
human mind right no
AIS yeah um I you know I think we're
going to have to deal with AI so we
better find a productive way to deal
with it in some way right absolutely so
I want a couple final thoughts here on
there's a author will Durant who
summarizes Aristotle's Poetics position
as the art the aim of art is to
represent not the outward appearance of
things but their inward significance and
so we can take photos and how like
perfect representations of things but
what what is the point of art is it to
uh produce art for Arts sake or for
money sake like what what is the actual
Taos the ends of
art yeah and I I kind of think for any
given work of art it's probably got
multiple ones right I mean you can you
can ask an artist why did you paint this
this way and they'll give you some great
song and dance and story which they
might be making up on the spot or it
might correspond to their artist
statement about oh I was you know
thinking about this they do want to sell
their work you they do want to survive
so well but that's it's art to to
survive if they had another way to
survive and actually produce their art
it might be different art but regardless
we we're at the end of our show here and
so um we leave you today with the words
of President John F Kennedy if art is to
nourish the roots of our culture Society
must set the artist free to follow his
vision wherever it takes him
[Music]
oh